tu le fais exprès tu vas bien que je
suis au téléphone tu viens de bloquer la
porte je travaille c'est pas une raison
pour toute la merde
parce que la porte bloquée
attention
ça y est sinon ça peut pas ouvrir
voilà sinon ça bloque la porte
cette [__] de porte ah ouais peut-être
allez au revoir je vais rentrer pour le
souper je devrais arriver vers
5h35 dans ton printemps pardon c'est mon
père
c'est mon téléphone c'est moi qui
compose là c'est moi qui appelle Chris
je veux te malaise je te laisse pas je
vois pas je pleure
je suis en train de parler à mon chat à
mon chat mon amour
du front tout le tour de la tête
lâchez-moi monsieur
je dois téléphoner c'est super important
je suis en retard pour un rendez-vous je
m'en fous moi qu'est-ce que tu me dis ça
moi je m'en fous c'est mon téléphone
pourquoi tu prends mon téléphone
ok voulez-vous de l'argent non non
allô
j'ai pris un téléphone publique
téléphone sans savoir sans demander aux
gens comme ça mais oui normalement c'est
comme ça que ça se passe on met 25 sous
et puis c'est tout on a la communication
puis après on raccroche et tous ces
mois oui J'arrive ok je vais raccrocher
là bye bye
un bisou
un bisou en plus mais vous êtes malade
mon téléphone c'est à moi c'est mon
téléphone à moi c'est mon miel
ok mon amour
ok on se rejoint
tu m'as même pas laissé ton numéro le
seigneur des anus première
bonjour bonjour
ça c'est vraiment interdit
et ça tombe vraiment
le respect du tournage c'est toi
allez arrête arrête arrête
comme la Bresse
première bonjour
un peu le son la radio s'il vous plaît
comment baisser le son de la radio je
suis désolé je suis chez moi quand même
hein
désolé je suis désolé vous inquiétez pas
vous partez vous sortez je suis désolé
touchez moi quand même hein je suis
désolé allez-y
j'appelle la police
allez-y eh c'est une blague pour la
caméra cachée
ah oui oui
oui
[Musique]
attends attends
ne pas regarder par la fenêtre
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous sortez du véhicule police nationale
en plus
à éviter ce que vous faites là
si vous voulez que je sorte le carnet de
ta bramoises dans pas longtemps ça va ça
va secouer encore plus
je peux la finir
vous pouvez finir
immédiatement dans 5 minutes d'accord
vous pouvez m'aider à porter ma glace
jusqu'à ma voiture
s'il vous plaît
c'est bon
oh là là qu'est-ce qu'elle est lourde
c'est bon là
voilà nickel merci beaucoup
prenez moi l'arrière voilà parfait
merci Monsieur alors je suis vraiment
embêté
qu'est-ce que c'est lourd oh là là ça va
on fait du lèche vitrine nous
auriez pas un chiffon dans le coffre un
truc comme ça pour qu'elle ait la glace
introduisez encore encore ça va s'abîmer
il faudrait vraiment un chiffon elle va
pas tomber comme ça la glace
remettez-vous au bout là parce que j'ai
peur qu'elle tombe
chercher avec moi chercher bien
on a trouvé un truc
merci beaucoup c'était très sympa petit
bisou
merci beaucoup tant de prendre un café
je sais pas j'ai le droit de prendre un
café
venez me voir venez me voir
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
vous pouvez rester là ça vous dérange
pas
ouais
petite copine qui vient
pour 2 minutes 30 là
plaisanter là ou quoi
vous descendez directement
deux minutes
s'il vous plaît
ça va mieux
c'est un nouveau produit que nous
sortons en France les saucisson de chien
100% pur bête
avec du chien
c'est du bâton de berger allemand
des teckels vous savez les teckels c'est
tout long c'est la forme d'un saucisson
déjà on les met directement dans la
machine on les fils
c'est pas des bâtards quand même hein
bien vigoureux sur le poil brillant
c'est sublime c'est un nouveau produit
qui vient de sortir c'est fait avec des
chiens
c'est malheureux pour les bêtes
malheureux c'est vrai c'est pas des
chiens domestiques non plus c'est des
chiens de laboratoire
ils sont rien on les en parle oui
pourquoi pas ou des escargots et ça
c'est du c'est du bassin
vous avez mangé du Teckel vous avez
mangé celui-là
j'ai envie de faire une blague à des
copains alors leur faire bouffer avec
une bouteille de vos gèle à faire
bouffer du saucisson de chien qu'il est
bon hein
je sais que là-bas ils ont des
boucheries de chien en Allemagne
à la SPA et puis quand la SPA peut plus
les garder et ils vont directement
charcuterie merci mais si c'est vrai
mais ça a toujours existé vous avez déjà
dit que j'ai mangé du chien en Allemagne
tu as jamais voulu m'écouter quoi il est
bon ou il est pas bon mais bon c'est un
bon toutou à sa mémère ça mord pas oui
je m'en doute
trottoirs propres et bien manger que des
trottoirs sales et manger de la mer
c'est sûr
je prends celui-là je vais prendre
celui-là
je préfère je suis allergique aux
couleurs grises je préfère le blanc
qu'est-ce qu'il y a il faut remonter
la vitre
d'avoir la vie trouver
quelque chose il y a un papier comme
quoi j'ai pas le droit d'avoir la vitre
ouverte
en voiture parce que je vous dis j'ai la
tarte écolier alors on va pas on va pas
se rendre à malako
je veux pas que vous démarriez moi j'ai
envie de me reposer là une heure dans
votre taxi
et je paye ou pas je paye ou pas c'est
pas un lieu de repos monsieur vous
pouvez me parler si vous voulez vous
pouvez me parler c'est pas un problème
je vais pas vous déranger non mais juste
pour m'endormir
racontez-moi une histoire quelque chose
je vais rue du Dragon
on y va quand même ben oui
je peux pas vous emmener à 20 mètres
je veux bien mais enfin là ça finit par
faire beau pas loin vous comprenez vous
emmener en taxi quand même mais pourquoi
elle est là voyons
dépêchez-vous parce que j'ai pas que ça
à faire non plus je vous emmènerai pas
c'est pas la peine
[Musique]
je vais prendre votre numéro vous allez
passer en conseil en conseil de
discipline
dans votre taxi et que vous voulez pas
voilà et j'ai le droit c'est pour faire
chier
le monde vous avez envie de m'emmerder
c'est pas de ma faute si c'est tombé sur
vous
mettez tous ces sacs là on m'a dit les
poubelles c'est ici
et j'ai pas envie d'avoir des poubelles
devant chez moi
[Musique]
vous avez un immeuble ben non je dis
ménage
alors vous ne mettez par là si vous
voulez pas me faire trimballer tout ça
si vous voulez j'appelle l'inspection de
de poubelle il y a pas de problème moi
si je veux rien inspection c'est quoi
l'inspection
c'est pour Monsieur hein c'est pas la
poubelle là
parce qu'il y en a plein
de débarrasser ça ouais comment
j'appelle la police mettez les ailleurs
s'il vous plaît
ça c'est un petit enfant qui est là qui
achète quelque chose voyez l'enfant il
reprend son vélo
est-ce qu'on fait de l'eau ah d'accord
vous prenez vos poubelles à la place si
vous achetez quelque chose
il va pas laisser le chat
fait la police est-ce que c'est
confidentiel ce qu'il y a dedans ça lui
fait une couverture
je promène mes poubelles
on fait comme on veut monsieur allez
venez venez vous voyez bien qu'ils sont
pas sympas ces gens allez venez les
enfants on rentre à la maison
d'avoir un petit garçon
ouais tu viens avec moi je le fais à
ce matin mais les gens s'accrochent pas
quoi mais il est tout option il est
mignon
j'ai pas d'argent je suis au bout du
rouleau
vous préférez qu'il soit dans la rue
avec moi
je peux pas vendre ma voiture et je m'en
sers dans ma voiture vous le vendez
des boîtes à manger et il évite son
assiette
si ça vous arrange pas vous faites deux
chèques le deuxième je le je le mets à
la fin du mois
à une question alors encore une question
elle c'est gratuit pourquoi vous vendez
parce que vous avez vous avez des
problèmes d'argent ouais j'ai joué au
casino j'ai tout perdu sur le 8 et il
faut que je rembourse parce que j'avais
fait un prêt et puis il rigole pas
là-bas
et la mer la mer elle est pas au courant
je veux pas qu'elle le sache je vais lui
dire que je l'ai perdu on fera vite
recherche s'il retrouve pas bon voilà
quoi
on ira aux objets trouvés et puis
si c'est sérieux déjà
ça s'achète pas même si j'avais les
moyens
j'ai les papiers j'ai tout avec
vous avez plus qu'à signer à faire le
chèque moi c'est une chose vous en avez
une autre il y a l'enfant aussi il faut
demander son avis aussi
[Musique]